it's not often that the land sandwiched
between great empires can survive
centuries of warfare and still come out
independent especially one whose people
speaks the same language as its larger
neighbor and jet mantova is one of those
lands and here it is today a sovereign
nation but why why does Moldova exist
so to begin Moldova or more davier as
it's been known through most of his
history is an old Romanian speaking
nation whose origins are in the 14th
century after it told the Hungarians
that it wasn't interested in being their
vassal anymore it spent the next century
fighting of the kingdom of Hungary
Valachi ER in the Polish Lithuanian
Commonwealth with varying levels of
success before the Ottomans turned up
who made it into a vassal in the early
16th century
now given Moldova's position on the
borders of the ottoman empire it should
be no surprise that it was a place which
saw war fairly often and much of that
war was with the recently expanded
Russian Empire and these two went to war
a lot and in 1812 half of Madhavi
islands collectively known as Bessarabia
were annexed into the russian empire in
1859 as a result of losing the Crimean
War the Russians handed over this
territory to what was left of Moldavia
which promptly formed the united
provinces with Valachi which would soon
afterwards take the name romania due to
some conflicts over access to the Danube
Russia ended up getting these lands back
a mere 20 years later time marched on
and World War one as you know Romania
joined the auntaunt got squashed in then
rejoined when the Central Powers were on
the back foot when the war was over in
the Russian Empire had collapsed because
Lenin Romania jumped on the opportunity
with the support of BES Arabia's
politicians annexed the region before it
expanded to this after the Treaty of
Trianon so into the 20th century Moldova
was a part of Romania and the people who
lived there were perfectly happy with
this arrangement someone who wasn't
happy with the arrangement was Joseph
Stalin who wanted Bessarabia back under
the control of Moscow in 1939 the USSR
in Germany signed the Molotov Ribbentrop
pact which secretly divided Eastern
Europe up between him and acknowledged
Soviet ownership of Bessarabia the next
year Stalin gave Romania an ultimatum
give his best arabia or we'll just take
it anyway Romania acquiesced in the USSR
annex the region during the course of
World War 2 Romania briefly occupied the
region again but that wouldn't last
these lands were transferred with the
Ukraine and the rest became the more
Davian Soviet Socialist Republic over
its lifetime in the USSR the government
was keen to stress that the Moldavian
and Romanian people's were different it
implemented linguistic reforms which
meant that the Moldavian language
use the Cyrillic alphabet as opposed to
the Latin one which Romania had adopted
in the previous century throughout its
time in the USSR Moldova was a sore spot
in relations between Moscow and
Bucharest and Romania's politicians made
it clear that they still believed it to
be a rightful part of Romania like all
of the things Soviet the Moldavian SSR
began tying in the late 1980s this was
when Gorbachev opened up the press and I
allowed the Soviet republics to discuss
their futures in the hopes that these
new freedoms would maintain the USSR but
fun fact
no Moldavia independence movement sprang
up quickly and Representatives there
reversed the adoption of the Cyrillic
alphabet and they soon afterwards
declared the Moldavia and Romanian
people to be one and the same you should
know though that there were many there
who wish to remain a part of the USSR
and when independence seemed inevitable
they themselves declared independence
they created the state of Transnistria
which still exists to this day but isn't
recognized by many nations
so why didn't Moldavia which soon took
the name Moldova join Romania well part
of it was timing Romania was having its
own troubles with anti-communist
revolution when the dust from that was
settled Gorbachev pressured the new
president to respect the USSR's borders
which he did and after that much of the
potential momentum was gone because
despite the declaration of Madhavi and
unity with Romania many people
especially in the south where Ukrainian
or Russian and for them the idea of
joining Romania wasn't so enchanting and
so in the end they didn't after which
Moldova would remain an independent
nation I hope you enjoyed this episode
and a special thanks to all my patreon
supporters James vis annette marvin
castle a man of culture kelly moneymaker
Danny Maloney John bisque is Rob
Waterhouse mo Aaron the white James
Castaneda Gustav Swan Jordan long ray
Marcus Ozma spinning three plates
cooling Castleman filled oink oink
Rashid Ali David Silverman easy Maggie
packs Kowski Spencer Lightfoot Winston K
word Robert Wetzel Lexy Schwinn Anthony
Beckett and Skye Chappell
I mean Bessarabia is a much better name
though